anyway um welcome i didn't even know we
were going to do this today
i was down here no not not that i
i want to celebrate the baby but um i
was down here i was playing
my video games going i'm just because i
have so much to do tomorrow
and i've you know this and that and i
was just like
today is my day just to relax i'm still
i also i'm still i don't feel that well
physically and um
and i hear his voice you know come into
the garage and i
um my reaction is like
first rage you know like what is he
doing here is he
has something to do with like some ads
nothing new
right no the rage is nothing new no no
if i expect george
there's no rage oh but if it's a
surprise
george so what's he supposed to do to
unsurprise you not be here
no whenever you have your headphones on
i always like just say something when i
walk in to make sure i don't like
shock you and then a shock rage is going
to be there
what do you say you make just a noise
like a little whistle howdy bobby
yeah yeah he does something like that
then he goes
oh god nine o'clock
and then he um then and then the
realization is like oh yeah i think we
are doing something
and then he brings in the balloons and
i'm like oh it's his
baby and then i said something really
rooty i really apologize
i said something so rude and when i said
it i'm like
why did you say that i i i i it's like
who am i
what was it i go well he goes i go the
baby's not here
and he goes please it is coming though
and i go well what if it doesn't
hey bobby i know as soon as i said that
i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's so bad if you if let's
say i was pregnant and you said that
[ __ ] to me
oh my god it would be like you'd get
jewels to stab me with her knives
well no it would be more than that yeah
and then he did
a he did something what i call
the white man's patience move oh how do
you what's that
w m p w-m-p-m yeah yeah and what he does
is
he wants to lash out but what some white
people do
is they refrain from doing that and they
co they analyze
right so i could see him just kind of
he's kept quiet he was analyzing how do
i respond to that
and he and his choice was no response
right
and so then i went oh dude i don't know
why i said i'm so sorry
it's a good move that you did because
today we could have started a fight well
usually i try a little joke which uh
then you just pounce on like let me okay
let's
oh let's let's re let's play that over
again and let me secure the joke okay
so all right okay
howdy bobby oh [ __ ] oh you're
oh [ __ ] the baby oh yeah that's why
you're here
we're doing something yeah it's a
special episode for my baby yeah yeah so
you got the balloons um
but the baby's not here oh that's coming
in like about a month or so yeah but
what if it
doesn't um
a lot of things don't come
but uh that's a slam that's his
deep slam a lot of things don't come
wow that burns you should
[ __ ] do roast battles bro i would
love that haven't happened
man you you're up there with jeff ross a
towel i mean
it's just like burning a lot of things
don't come
oh [ __ ] if there was a crowd here
you would hear this oh you would hear
that
it's like things just people stand oh in
your face bobby that's what you hear
you [ __ ] you know what i would have
said something along the lines of like
you know at least i don't shoot blanks
at least i got a full load i don't want
to ever go that get that deep
or or oh that's the only way to play
with this man or at least i'm
responsible enough to like you know
do what's right and and have a baby with
you know my
the woman that i love unlike a guy a 50
year old guy
playing video games all day who has no
you know something like that
that would have been like oh [ __ ] i'm
going to kill this guy
yeah but you would right that would have
been a good you know what i mean and
then no podcast
no podcast doesn't matter sometimes you
gotta win baby
sometimes in life you gotta win george
and i'm trying to teach you that
so um the baby's coming it's a baby
shower
episode um our first baby our first
tiger belly
belly baby how exciting you did the test
we do we know what the gender is
yeah it's a boy it's a boy
congratulations did i remember that
or just the blue was that said before
yes it was many times
i mean the look at it it says boy it's a
boy right there on the giraffe oh